[Music]  I'm a pastor that doesn't believe in  Christ I'm a pastor because it's an easy  way to make a living I'm a pastor but I  don't know if I even believe in God  anymore neither my wife nor my  congregation know that I'm addicted to  porn I'm a pastor but I'm agnostic I  don't know how to step down without  disappointing everyone I'm a pastor but  I've fallen from where I should be I'm  on the other side of the tracks now I  know I should go back but it's just so  hard I'm a minister  and it bothers me that I'm not allowed  to officiate gay marriage I don't agree  with it but I don't agree with taking  away people's rights either I'm a priest  and I believe gay people make the world  a better place I'm a priest and my wife  and I are swingers nothing like being a  pastor on Saturday night with no message  to deliver Sunday morning  [Music]